instead I will let him uh come up and I
match that young movement and then I
just pull him off that precarious face
okay
so again he goes
he's pulling the Right Touch so you can
you can uh touch with one finger and
he's going and you'll be able to pull
that off
you've had you don't you don't need your
base at all because you can ground after
on one face go ahead and you'll pull
that off so we're already at that sticky
part do you see
and I can push it back even okay you can
move it because there's always yawn you
want to try to release more and you
could do different you could do all
those stuff but here
um it looks like because he's going up
against my hand that
um
that that is somehow mechanically
responsible for what we're seeing again
I do acknowledge that we've set him up
like this because it's easier to get the
feeling okay uh and we have to have the
feeling in order to keep trying to find
that feeling and then develop that skill
uh but in terms of energy there should
be no reason why I have to be here
you understand I I can be here in front
and he goes to to lift his arm again if
I'm too light he'll slide off if I'm too
heavy it's pushing me you see that but I
can that is Young and he goes and I can
start pulling that thing
from not being on top of it